[Music]
and don't fall for it news submitted by
teriyaki soda fires [ __ ] here are 5
mental traps that successfully that
successful people never fall for
according to psychologists Oh mental
traps number 1 tinder that's not mental
trap that's a dick trap now that's a
mental trap thing unless you something
passes it's gonna come from it true
massage herpes the Kazakh does it does
the risk outweighed the reward
that's why abstinence only education is
the only way that's true thank you
amen okay she says with a baby I was
married she's married pal Oh
number one I also shot it from afar
respectfully but I'm still very tight
baby you have to be so number one is
emotional reasoning mistaking our
emotions as evidence for the truth is
one of the most common mental traps we
fall into an example is I feel like my
ideas are worthless
therefore I shouldn't share them in this
meeting so they're saying that emotional
reasoning can often cause us to make
poor choices that's for people they mix
what they're feeling versus what's
actually the evidence to combat
emotional reasoning cognitive therapist
suggests asking yourself questions like
what are the facts that support my
emotionally based determination or is it
possible that my feelings are clouded by
some bias that I ought to be up to be
reevaluated that when you stop
transforming your feelings into truths
you gain the logic and clarity that will
allow you to make smarter decisions
that's what they'll really like in our
writing room where we constantly are
trying to write the best script for the
character and like the story so we're
constantly just shooting out ideas and
pitching them but we're not married to
any single one of them right verses I
can always tell when we're like in a
more beginner creative circle where
people pitch their ideas
that's the first one they ever had only
very few as soon as someone shits on
that one you see them just kind of
crumbled you like my idea but for me all
ideas are worthless until it's proven
that it's a good one
there's nothing more annoying than
somebody thinks her idea is so sick yeah
that when you write when you even just
like like you're like okay you play with
a little bit yeah we just try to
understand it and you could just see
them Crumlin I'm not attacking you
ladies how do you guys feel about that
like if somebody like here's your idea
it immediately gives you feedback or
criticism do you take that do you take
are you receiving of it when I was first
doing either business or a creative
session like of course you know because
it's something that you're very
vulnerable with and something you come
up with and you might not necessarily
think it's sick as [ __ ] but you're like
scared but you're like I still want to
share this and then if someone like a
text that you kind of do take it
personally but because I've been doing
it for so long that now it's like okay
whatever like it didn't work cool so
time matters for me experience yeah for
me it was experience I think this is
something I'm learning to grow out of
but I do like hurt like attached my
identity to the things that come out of
my mouth or whatever it is that I'm
experiencing or like my emotions do
really cloud a lot of my experiences so
I am trying to detach a little bit so
like my initial reaction if someone
would start criticizing an idea that I
brought Cynthia Bowles immediately I'd
be like ow but now I'm like wait hold on
let me [ __ ] move that aside yeah what
are you trying to do like what are you
trying to say like yeah let's work this
[ __ ] out but that's really been
struggling like what tell him up my girl
that she gives bad head and I don't know
how to like give her the correct
criticism you're supposed to do well it
comes to comes to experience if she
gives more head there's more detached
from the head you know you can do is you
could take her head and just make her do
it the right way tried that she doesn't
like when I
drunk and then you take her head and
excuse us drunk head is worth of drugs
yeah she just makes a mess all over the
place it's like a [ __ ] baby with a
loose bottle top maybe get her really
high and then take your head and just do
it right you don't want me to get a good
head and then you put it between the two
poles in the stairs I salvaged it in
there and then you move your dick the
way you want to be done hey so is there
anything I can improve in okay so this
is this is where you can hey is there
anything that I can improve it and then
the person is like okay where's in the
you can improve obviously with more tech
what if what if your your visual or what
if she's a visual yeah why don't you
show her I was going to just have like
like just sixteen screens of porn on and
it's just all head on all the screens
that's crazy
did you ever think about maybe like
using your feet huh that's great I never
thought of that we should try it
hey there what a really professional job
look big it's just like you don't have
it I don't need the pho that snot you
don't want it thrown up on a half-open
stop I've got here like I go like that
don't do that it seemed like why'd you
do that I was like cuz I don't know what
else to tell you to do do that okay help
us out what's she doing
help us out what's she doing wrong like
she tries to do that the ads like ah
once I poured it out was a hit of stuff
with a chick I was like stop that's the
penis like don't do that likes not at
all I like that right it's like she put
out another time she tried to spit miss
my dick hit my Billy but now we got a
fight yeah you no longer a woman oh my
woman you're a human we're about to
fight put some shoes on let's go outside
maybe she went outside I locked the door
maybe she read Cosmo and they said
lubricate the guy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Cosmo leader Cosmo anyway moving
on to these mental traps
does she like being knighted I played a
little bit I feel like you think they
care about minor tips answers and it was
just all for the [ __ ] bit I can set
you up yes really [ __ ] duck down in
there I'm like oh [ __ ] okay we're gonna
help I bunker here let me share it for
some other Beach I should have [ __ ]
known better I'm so stupid it was too
far and I will say this those were great
answers and I think that is the point
that you guys said and that you can omit
that at one point you weren't receptive
of it right but now that you are the
show's growth it also shows the same
question and see how where she is in
like her state of mind she's ready to
receive this information guys don't
understand he's setting up again right
now so here admit it so here invites you
over
he makes Thanksgiving dinner he sits it
down and you guys are ready to eat and
then he pulls the [ __ ] number to
answer deal with it just hurt are you
ready okay number two and I'm doing this
to you right now get out get out
you know you're right now to here nobody
here is blaming
we engage in I thought it was a stupid
question - but I'm like what's - here I
mean I should well you sure didn't
answer like a stupid question no I want
it on care I gave them [ __ ] respect
okay I'm sorry
blaming okay blaming so when we engaged
him in blaming we hold others
accountable for what it's so fun to
blame is it my own actions and feelings
so an example is on your way to work
your cat escaped through the door you
great you say now I'm gonna be late and
it's the cat's fault so we often blame
others stupid ass [ __ ] let's preserve
our sense of self-esteem by avoiding
awareness of our own flaws or failings
maybe it's not your girl's fault best
you can suck but failing to take
responsibility for the consequences of
your own behavior means you're not
learning from your mistakes
and being able to grow through your
experiences especially the unpleasant
ones is crucial to success not if the
shoe stink though how do you be
empathetic if you're gonna be late for
work and I stupid [ __ ] cat left you
still [ __ ] labeling hey man
damn I can't really listen to get out
like you're [ __ ] late James are you
fired I think what the article trying to
say you want to empathize with all the
serial animal killers I see why they
killed all those cats so they won't be
late anymore
number three catastrophize ation another
cat cat booties is not working
catastrophe and it missed the cat melt
even the first one know it says many of
us have fallen down the negative spiral
of expecting the worst the worst of the
worst all the [ __ ] time so an example
is the news report the news reports that
a storm is approaching you start to
imagine all the bad things that can
happen what if my house gets destroyed
what if someone I love gets hurt what if
I get hurt so fear especially irrational
fear plays a big part in catastrophizing
that [ __ ] prevents people from being
successful for sure girls do you do that
says we're always anticipating the word
[ __ ] out of here you [ __ ] ass I told
my girlfriend that she doesn't suck my
dick good she's fearful I hate you and
your [ __ ] Japanese shirt yeah that's
cuz you're blaming me you haven't been
pathetic at all to your situation I
don't blame you
nice this is evolved just crawling good
for you it was a good job it was a joke
but we still got some answers it was
really good I really enjoyed your answer
and yours too I don't like being played
okay well well it's the [ __ ] America
I like that you guys brought this like
PhD dissertation that your wife is that
I practice yeah I was that my day would
come that I would get to give some good
advice and yeah I still may come to just
one today
[Music]
I was really concerned about your girl
knocking oh no I get bum here it had to
be because the what you're describing is
bomb head it was so it's so good since I
want my friends to get it let you really
suit otherwise it
[Music]